what does an outline look like well for
me on these assignments that I do
they're usually ten or twelve pages and
it's the entire story treatment and it's
not just line by line I mean there are
some hot lines it's just it's a line in
line but for these movies for television
they're a tax so everything has to be
broken down but it as a story so if you
were to sit down and read it you'd be
reading the story of the movie which i
think is essential to create because I
find that many in fact I've had friends
that do this so I'm just gonna sit down
and I have the vague idea and I'm just
gonna write and I'm like you'll you'll
be lost in the barren wasteland of Act
two with no water you'll be in the
desert you'll be lost and you'll wonder
how you're gonna trudge through those 75
pages or whatever I'm a huge advocate of
outlines before starting writing and I
know it's it's probably 50 60 70 percent
of the work you do because it makes the
load a lot easier and you can write a
faster screenplay if you have an outline
now that doesn't say there's room
there's no room for changes or
improvising but if you don't have a
solid roadmap going in it's almost like
a pre draft of a first draft and I'm not
an advocate I know there's people say
that about the vomit draft or just spill
it out but I don't have the luxury of
spelling it out on my assignment jobs I
don't I really have to turn in let's say
out of a ten scale I've got to turn in
probably an eight and eight you know out
of ten because I'm now holding up
development you know and I've also done
rewrites on other screenwriters work
projects that have that were to page one
rewrites which means that the script
that they have went through multiple
drafts and still is not there and they
have a buyer they have a network who's
waiting on the script and so I've also
been hired to do rewrite job where I can
come in but it's like a page one rewrite
where see the script that you have you
can't use any of it the names yes the
concept yes but you basically and that's
that's something that I've learned how
to do which is good because there is a
lot of rewrite work out there and and
some writers look down on it upon oh you
know but uh but an example is that I
took a rewrite job and that ended up
being three more jobs with the same
company because that opened the door for
them and then they were thankful for
that so you never know
what opportunity is is gonna you know
you're going to either turn down or
accept so but back to your point about
the outline I think is extremely
important to do an outline before your
screenplay because it's easier to work
out the problems there than it is
writing a complete first draft and
having just have so many problems and
also trained you like I said it's a it's
like you're an Olympic athlete it trains
you for the time when you do have to do
outlines because I'm not allowed to
write these assignments without an
outline that I have to create so they
won't just let me go to pages they mean
they have other people involved who have
to okay it so the outline is extremely
important in your book do you have any
examples of an actual outline I know
sometimes viewers will ask where do I
find a copy of an outline because it's
um I don't it's I'm sure you can find it
online but it's not it's not that
mysterious I mean there's there's
different there's a step outline there's
a there's a one sheet which is the one
one sheet of paper which is the concept
you know it's sort of a short synopsis
there's the logline which is even
smaller you know two or three sentences
so there's different steps and and you
have to have you have to have each along
the way because you have the quick pitch
I'm not interested then you have the
quick pitch and they go hmm I'm willing
to read something not the script but
I'll read a synopsis then you know
there's different steps of how how
interested they are to read what you
want is the final product the final
script is for them to read but the the
treatment I mean there's many different
for you know again like a step outline
I've done outlines that were 30 pages I
mean completely they just you triple it
you have the script
but everything had to be worked out
because it was a very technical the way
the film was gonna be shot was from from
like an iPhone and from different things
and so really had to be spelled out you
know there was no because on the set you
just can't leave it up to chance so
that's you know but at that point I
could have written a script in weeks
because it was all figured out you know
I figured it out already and you want
that outline for those dark periods when
you're stuck you don't want to be stuck
trying to figure out plot points when
you should be filling pages that's the
worst part that's the worst place to be
how long does it usually take you to
write an outline it's let's see from
once the concept it's like two weeks and
and we're working every day and then
that usually ends up being 12 or 15
pages as the outline in my in my
experience with my producers and that
outline is then rewritten sometimes two
or three times I mean I have to you know
I get notes on the outline before I'm
allowed to go to the script so the
script is like the final once we okay
the outline then go to pages and that's
not to say there they don't change their
mind once the scripts finished because
that's that's the crazy part because you
see yeah but you agreed to in the
outline but we built the house and now
we don't kind of like the way it looks
you know we thought we did and so that
happens too so you have to be you know
open and prepared for rewrites at all
stages but it does allow you to write a
faster first draft is to have a solid
outline because for me I have to see the
film in my head before I can write it
and I know that I have a lot of problems
ahead of me if I can't see it I mean I
don't I don't lock in like I've almost
seen the movie like you like when you
watch a movie you remember it I have to
see it that way and I know things are
working when I start to live and you
know the outlines good for living with
your characters you know you get to live
with them you get to you get to see how
the movie is working or doesn't
before you sit down and write that
screenplay which is building the house
you know that's almost at the pre
blueprint and in my opinion that's been
my experience but I know a lot of
writers just want to write down a couple
of lines and and wing it and there's so
many so many things that can go wrong
and why why not turn in your the most
amazing first draft you can I don't see
the the problem with that and in fact
like I say you have to when you're doing
assignment work you want the fewer
drafts you don't want eight drafts
because nothing's working you know you
want to turn that where they go Wow one
of my assignments I did two drafts and
two polishes were done that's what they
like they don't like five you're not
getting it that's where you get fired
and they hire somebody else who can
facilitate the notes and get it moving
you know it's it's it's creative but
it's also a business at the same time
unfortunately
you